Mit einfachen Verpackungstricks werden
Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
tagtäglich von der Lebensmittelindustrie
zum Kaufen animiert.
Wie das funktioniert, zeigt Sebastian Lege mit selbst hergestellten Gemüsechips.
Gemüsechips liegen voll im Trend und durch
geschickte Verpackung holen die
Hersteller fix ein paar Prozent mehr raus.
Das zeigt ein simpler Tütenvergleich.
Zweimal Gemüsechips: einmal Marke und
einmal No-Name.
SEBASTIAN: "Boah, ist da viel Luft drinne!"
"Lecker sind die!"
Beide Packungen kosten dasselbe: 1,99 Euro.
Und doch gibt es einen erheblichen Unterschied.
SEBASTIAN: "Ganz witzig: Hier sind 60 Gramm drin enthalten."
"Und hier 100!"
"Aber fast identisch!"
Ähnliche Packungsgröße, aber deutlich weniger Inhalt.
Nicht der einzige Kniff, mit dem Hersteller absahnen.
Ist es so simpel?
Sebastian will das testen.
Dazu macht er seine eigenen Gemüsechips, nach dem
Motto "Wenig Inhalt, viel Drumherum".
Ob das klappt?
SEBASTIAN: "Jetzt fehlt nur noch die richtige Verpackung mit ordentlich viel Luft drin."
Eine schwere Tüte in Retro-Papier-Optik, ein Etikett mit edlem Gemüsemotiv, Handschrift Design plus
Foto vom vermeintlichen Erzeuger - die ganze Packung verströmt hochwertiges Bio-Handwerksflair.
Fertig ist die Tüte für den Test.
100 Gramm würden reinpassen.
Sebastian füllt natürlich nur 50 Gramm hinein.
Damit die halbvolle Packung nicht so
schlapp aussieht, wendet er einen
beliebten Industrietrick an.
Aufpumpen mit Kohlendioxid. Das hält auch noch den Inhalt knackig.
SEBASTIAN: "Und hier ist meine CO2-Kanone."
"Mit richtig viel Luft auf dem Kompressor."
"Weil... wir wollen doch Geld verdienen!"
Eine halbleere Tüte zum vollen Preis.
Das merkt doch kein Mensch!
SEBASTIAN: "Gerade mal 50 Gramm drin. Sieht aber aus wie eine richtig große Portion."
Für Gemüse, Öl und Salz hat Sebastian gerade einmal 24 Cent bezahlt.
Wie die Hersteller den Endpreis genau
berechnen, ist ihr Geheimnis.
Aber satte Gewinnspannen sind garantiert.
Und Gemüsechips sind kein Einzelfall.
Bei jeder Form von Flocken und Knusperkram hat die Industrie leichtes Spiel.
Zum Beweis röntgen wir unterschiedliche
Verpackungen.
Beispiel Cornflakes: Die billigen von Penny sind immerhin zu gut 80 Prozent gefüllt.
Das teure Markenprodukt von Kellogg's
dagegen nur zu rund zwei Dritteln.
Auch bei Kartoffelchips ist viel Luft in der
Verpackung und wieder fällt auf:
Im Markenprodukt sind weniger Chips als in der No-Name-Variante.
Trendy ist teuer.
Beispiel Pfanni: Bei den nostalgischen
Stampfkartoffeln ist der Füllstand nur
etwa halb so hoch wie beim schlichten
Kartoffelbrei.
Der Preis für die größte Mogelpackung geht ans Studentenfutter.
Die Tüte ist nicht mal bis zur Mitte gefüllt!
HEIKE SILBER: "Eigentlich sagt der Gesetzgeber eine
Verpackung darf über den Inhalt nicht
hinwegtäuschen.
"Das heißt es ist eine
Irreführung, das ist eine Täuschung."
Die Hersteller führen technische Gründe an.
Die Maschinen könnten es nicht besser.
Wann eine Mogelpackung vorliegt, ist gesetzlich übrigens nicht genau geregelt.
Dafür gibt es Tipps, die ziemlich praxisfern klingen.
SILBER: "Hier sagt der Gesetzgeber: Ich kann ja als Verbraucher das ertasten."
"Wir finden, diese Verpackung könnte aber auch kleiner sein."
Bevor man blindlings auf Chipstüten herumdrückt, vergleicht man wohl besser die 100-Gramm-Preise.
Denn das lohnt sich, wie dieses Beispiel
zeigt.
Die Cornflakes links kosten 2,49 Euro, rechts 99 Cent.
Ungefähr gleiche Packungsgröße, weniger Inhalt.
So kommt man bei Kellogg's Cornflakes mit reichlich Luft im Karton auf etwa 65 Cent pro 100 Gramm.
Die Flakes der Penny-Eigenmarke kosten nicht mal ein Drittel.
Gleiches Bild beim nächsten Beispiel: 100
Gramm der Funny Frisch Chips kosten fast
doppelt so viel wie die Kartoffelchips
von Lidl - und das bei gleich großer Verpackung.
Die Luftnummer aber ist nur
ein beliebter Trick.
Immer mehr Verpackungen locken mit
Qualitätsversprechen.
Dabei bedient sich die Industrie eines
psychologisch sehr effektiven Kniffs.
SEBASTIAN: "Wahnsinn! Das gibt es jetzt auf jedem Produkt."
"Gibt es überhaupt noch Produkte ohne Qualitäts-
prädikat, ohne irgendeine Auslobung? ich glaube nicht."
Tatsache! Fast überall finden wir Siegel und Qualitätsversprechen.
Manche sind auch wirklich verbindlich.
Das sechseckige Biosiegel oder die rechteckige Variante der EU sind starke Siegel mit einem Gesetz dahinter.
Einsatz von Pestiziden und Tierschutz sind streng geregelt.
Wenn es um Produkte aus Entwicklungsländern geht, hilft das Fairtrade-Siegel bei der Kaufentscheidung
Es wird ebenfalls unabhängig kontrolliert.
SEBASTIAN: "Hier mal was, das ich kenne."
"Fairtrade. Damit der Bauer auch mal einen Euro mehr in der Tasche behält und nicht nur
die großen Konzerne den Reibach machen."
"Ist wirklich ein super Label!"
Aber was ist mit anderen bekannten Gütesiegeln?
SEBASTIAN: "Kennt man: das DLG-Siegel. Aber hier haben sie mal schön
von 2015 weiter gedruckt. Ist die Version
denn genau so gut wie damals?"
Einmal verliehen gilt das Siegel noch weitere zwei Jahre.
Und was sagt das aus? Nicht allzu viel!
Die Industrie testet sich selbst, bewertet vor allem Geschmack und Aroma.
Das Ergebnis: Über 80 Prozent der eingereichten Produkte werden prämiert.
SILBER: "Also bei den Produktsiegeln kann der Hersteller Siegel auf den Markt bringen,
wenn er bestimmte Kriterien dafür
festlegt, was für Verbraucher dann
ziemlich schwierig ist nachzuvollziehen."
"Wenn man im Supermarkt steht, das neue
Siegel sieht und dann die Kriterien nicht kennt."
"Das heißt, die Verbraucher müssen dann im Prinzip über das Internet oder über Recherche
nachvollziehen, woher die Kriterien kommen."
Hilfe bietet die Seite "siegelklarheit.de".
Oder die NABU-Siegel-App. Hier kann man Gütesiegel direkt scannen.
Immerhin eine Möglichkeit, sich zu informieren.
Praktisch machtlos ist man bei einer
weiteren Verpackungsmasche.
SEBASTIAN: "Was haben wir noch schönes?"
"Ha! Ein eigenes Label! Schonend
gepresst, aus wertvollen Keimen."
"Ist gleich wieder ein Qualitätsprädikat."
Auf immer mehr Verpackungen immer mehr Versprechen, die gut klingen,
aber nichts bedeuten müssen.
SEBASTIAN: "Hier ist auch noch was ganz witziges."
"Qualität aus Freude am Kaffee - Melitta Bentz."
"Pfiffiger Trick!"
Solange solche selbst erfundenen Siegel keine geschützten Begriffe enthalten,
unterliegen sie keiner Pflicht für
unabhängige Kontrollen.
SILBER: "Das ist ein klares Herstellersiegel."
"Der Hersteller macht es drauf, um hier eine Qualität entweder vorzutäuschen
oder die Qualität ist drin."
"Das kann man immer schwierig beurteilen."
"Aber hier prüft niemand nach, ob das
jetzt auch stimmt."
Auch Sebastian Lege braucht für seine selbst kreierte Chipstüte noch ein Siegel.
Dazu legt er kurzerhand selbst das Testkriterium fest.
Nämlich was schmeckt seinem Hund Kalle.
Zur Wahl stehen natürlich nur die eigenen Chips.
SEBASTIAN: "Langsam! Langsam!"
"Testsieger! Kalle hat gesagt: Das sind die
besten Gemüsechips!"
Ein Label ohne echte Aussagekraft und doch völlig legal.
Die Masche ist vom Gesetz her erlaubt.
Sebastian will die Wirkung der
Verpackung testen.
Dazu führt er seine selbstgemachten
Gemüsechips in drei unterschiedliche Tüten.
Zwei davon kennt man aus dem
Supermarktregal.
Die Dritte ist die selbst designte mit
dem Testsieger-Label.
"Drei verschiedene Verpackungen,
der Inhalt wird überall der gleiche sein."
"Mal sehen, ob die Leute sich von dem Siegel in die Irre führen lassen."
Schmecken die Tester Unterschiede?
Obwohl überall dasselbe drin ist?
Los geht's mit der ersten Tüte:
vermeintlich die Biochips von Penny.
TESTER: "Vom Geschmack her ist das ziemlich knusprig."
"Schon mal gut."
Tüte zwei: Sebastians selbst designte Chipspackung.
Wirkt sich die Premiumtüte auf den Geschmack aus?
TESTER: "Ganz anders, aber auch gut."
"Schon besser."
Die Tester schmecken erste Unterschiede.
TESTERIN: "Bisschen salziger."
SEBASTIAN: "Ok."
Die letzte Tüte stammt vom Markenprodukt Funny Frisch.
Die Packung verspricht besondere Würze - schmecken die gleichen Chips deshalb anders?
TESTERIN: "Kräftiger Geschmack."
"Damit kann man gut trinken."
TESTER: "Ich würde sagen, das ist mehr der breite Geschmack."
Unglaublich! Alle Probanden schmecken
Unterschiede.
Obwohl überall die gleichen Chips drin
sind.
Aber aus welcher Tüte schmeckt's am besten?
Zieht das Testsieger-Label?
TESTER: "Ich würde mir die greifen."
"Das wäre meine persönliche Auswahl."
SEBASTIAN: "Okay, wäre jetzt dein Favorit?"
TESTER: "Am besten fand ich die!"
TESTERIN: "Die schmecken mir besser."
TESTER: "Ich glaube, die haben mir am besten geschmeckt."
TESTERIN: "Wenn ich eine kaufen würde, dann die."
SEBASTIAN: "Du würdest dir diese kaufen."
TESTER: "Da hat für mich alles gestimmt."
"Von der Konsistenz her, nicht zu knackig, nicht zu trocken."
"Würzung war super."
SEBASTIAN: "Hier ist überall das Gleiche drin."
TESTER: "Nein!" - SEBASTIAN: "Doch!"
SEBASTIAN: "Doch, hier ist überall das Gleiche drin."
"Und hier steht ja Testsieger. Weißt
du wer der Tester war?"
"Mein Hund."
TESTERIN: "Dein Hund?"
Tatsächlich: Der Trick funktioniert. Die
Tester haben sich von der aufgemotzten
Packung in die Irre führen lassen.
Ausnahmslos alle schmeckten Unterschiede, wo gar keine waren.
Die meisten hätten sich für Sebastians Trickverpackung mit Wertlos-Siegel und leeren Versprechen entschieden.
Für Experten kein Zufall: Siegel und Slogans wirken sogar über das eigentliche Versprechen hinaus.
So etwas nennt man Überstrahlungseffekt.
Kunden schreiben einem Produkt auch
Qualitäten zu, die gar nicht versprochen wurden.
BORNEMANN: "Da finden wir eben diesen Überstrahlungseffekt."
"Man kann beispielsweise zeigen, dass wenn ich Kartoffelchips habe,
dass wenn ich Schokoladenriegel habe,
die beispielsweise ein Biolabel tragen,
Gütesiegel tragen,
dass die auch als weniger gesundheitsschädlich
wahrgenommen werden,
obwohl natürlich die Inhaltsstoffe, die in einem Bioprodukt sind, einem Schokoriegel oder Kartoffelchips,
die gleichen sind sie sind nur unter anderen Bedingungen hergestellt worden."
Das nutzen die Firmen aus.
Sie drucken auf ihre Produkte Siegel oder siegelartige Buttons, wo sie nur können.
Und wir werden regelrecht zum Kauf verleitet.
Was also können wir tun?
BORNEMANN: "Bei der aktuellen Situation, so wie wir sie haben,
was diese gesundheitsbezogenen Aussagen angeht, wäre fast die Empfehlung,
die einfach erstmal zu ignorieren und dann
doch in die Zutatenliste zu gehen, in die
Nährwertkennzeichnung zu gehen,
sich das anzuschauen."
Heißt: Der Blick auf die Zutaten gibt nach wie vor mehr Aufschluss über das Produkt als die meisten Siegel.
Lasst ihr euch von den Verpackungstricks in die Irre führen?
Und welchen Qualitätssiegeln vertraut
ihr wirklich?
Sagt es uns in den Kommentaren!
Und wo ist die besten Lebensmittel gibt
und was wirklich drin steckt, zeigen wir
euch auf unserem Kanal ZDFbesseresser.